the biggest honor when chill says your
youtube channel i think that that
[ __ ] ship y'all get into is scary
enough shipyard
awful trippy on it it was a shipyard
there's a connor a branch touch connor's
leggings like it's a streak i swear
it runs off something ran over my leg
you can watch the video slow it down you
see it's a twig he's like oh gosh
there's a snake or something you can't
see it's a [ __ ] twist
chris just wants me to be a little [ __ ]
and then there's a spider was
oh you allowed to film though
uh
it's kind of like public access it's
just you just walk through yeah there's
no sign that says no
there's no entry sign there's always a
better one that's saying no entry right
don't go in there you know we did
actually go to one there was like no
entry we did it yeah
so be careful don't enter but it doesn't
say don't film
that's the pachinko loophole right
i figured if there's no sign saying you
can't go in and it's
publicly accessible i mean yeah
there was no wall or anything we didn't
like climb a fence literally just like
you you're on a road you just there's
like a patch of grass you walk into the
grass and you're there
yeah so chris it's been it's been a good
year for you you'd say somebody made a
lot of videos well somebody sent me a
message being like on the trash taste
podcast to start the year your like um
new year's resolution was to do
something crazy and wacky and you got
the studio and you met came out to love
it yeah so it kind of did pretty crazy
i'm pretty happy with how the years ago
you literally
yeah but everyone's like when you're
doing something with gun and so it's
true that's why you're like 2022.
i'll do a six-part travel series with
gaunt called take him for granted
have you been like writing these jokes
and writing them all down i'm just a
genius and i prepared that three months
ago yeah he's been waiting to say that i
want to tell you i want to abuse gantt
through physical activity
i want to like climb krakatoa with god i
want to go to crack it's like you know
just still like crazy like christmas
using my body taking me to wanker sober
is that how it's pronounced or is that
just how it goes it's not it's just him
but
he's still wanking there
because he can't yeah because uh we went
to uh we went to a bar with jan the
other day and he goes chris just made me
eat wank sober and i'm just like [ __ ]
sober what's going on what [ __ ] that was
all right
it was good too much but i was like why
do i have to ruin my body for your
[ __ ] channel chris how about how do i
run ruin my body for my channel
i did i you know
he ruined his mind for you yeah
on the crane games george ptsd high
blood pressure and then like they did a
fairy he was like it was a very it's
really good we're on a fair [ __ ]
i got really seasick and i had to like
lie down the entire shoot otherwise i
stood up i was like
it was also a horrible mood at least my
videos they're like fun oh yeah yeah
going to an abandoned shipyard at 1 a.m
freezing cold who wouldn't want to do
that would you do you want to go to the
band and ship your [ __ ] yeah there you
go yeah it's super fun take it for
granted it's coming soon
how long does that youtube think of the
name wacky weekends
what'd that come that was like the uh
i said it was a joke i was like could
you think of a better one we'd do
something like wacky on a weekend
probably around the same amount of time
as it took the anime man to be formed
as in five seconds nothing else worked
though that was snappy
yeah
wonderful wonder weekend wicked weekend
chris and connor i think rocky weekend
the chris and connor show
chris and connor abroad in japan
[ __ ] killed me on the bridge as well
that bridge was so dangerous that was
actually so dangerous
it was pretty fun that was pretty ropey
this poor kid nearly died on that bridge
went to that the worst hotel in japan i
still actually
i think that is the worst thing i've
done this year i've done a lot of
horrible [ __ ] but like like a cessna
over an active volcano like this hotel
room we went to i i still can't get the
smell of that room at my head
i wish you were there because you should
have seen like the three hours of chris
just being like we should we got to stay
haven't we and i'm like no if you watch
the video you can see our eyes go red
over the period of the shoot because the
air is just filled with like
all kinds of mold everywhere
you're asthmatic
you know
obviously we'd already paid for the room
but it was such a state where i was like
would you get another cheap hotel that
isn't bad yeah because you know why why
why stay here yeah and chris was just
like i think we should stay here i'm
like for what reason chris
well even though i was dying there's
something still awkward about going down
to a hotel desk after two hours be like
oh we've got to go now bye
it's not that chris was worried about
the content we already got the content
we filmed the room chris was like he
just didn't want to go and confront the
staff that we were checking out all
right and i was like i'll [ __ ] do it
like no come on we can't do that it's
really british man of honor
and like all their clientele here are
checking out after one hour why do you
think that is
that's true yeah
people are coming and going well i
discovered that night we did you know we
showed you that was in the air
there was blood on the wall as well
there was blood on the wall under the
giant
blood stain on his mattress they hadn't
hovered under the bed they just hoovered
around the bed and if you lifted the
beds in the videos massive piles of dust
massive layers like how is it still in
operation
i think
so
[Music]
let me try to check into another hotel
in japan we discovered that it's really
hard to check into a hotel past sort of
eleven twelve years yeah yeah and the
staff are really angry at this nice
hotel we tried to get in they were like
what do you want our room
no we can't do it and then they were
just like being really dicks about it
yeah we were like we have a room with
two beds and they were like no we don't
have one then we're like how about two
rooms with one bed and they were like
okay that's that's yeah yeah wow yeah
it's like all right well i guess we
won't pay you there like i guess there's
voice now it's strange i understand it's
pretty inconvenience about what yeah
definitely i mean you're in the service
industry yeah
literally yeah the person
yes the one star hotel was more affable
than the people at the four-star hotel
and that's the irony i think it was
actually quite nice
they were like oh my god people are
actually staying here oh my god money
what the [ __ ]
a customer there's a really sketchy area
as well yeah it's really seedy
well you don't have a hotel like that in
a [ __ ] uptown area do you yeah but
it's so hard to talk about this without
sounding like a [ __ ] snot but it was
really just awful it was so bad well i
mean it's the worst hotel right of
course you're not going to be like yeah
it was lovely it was a commonwealth it
was the worst so something like that in
the comments though you've got a roof
over your head it's more than most and
it's like [ __ ] off mate this roof over
my head's going to kill me in one hour
[ __ ] off
i suppose i started in a hotel room and
actively like worried about my physical
health yeah yeah yeah you know that's
that's quite a weird sensation
i was googling like how many types of
mold are there and i was like going
around the room spotting or
if there's mold in the room you should
probably leave as soon as possible but
that the kicker was like when connor
pulled the blanket back and it was just
a big patch of blood on my bed but i was
like oh it's time to go like you can't
see you can't sleep
like either somebody was stabbed and
they were bleeding on the bed or someone
missed the time of month i think yeah it
looks like that yikes it was um either
way no thank you because uh yeah that i
would also get out take it for granted
are you ready
did you find it huh did i find that
hotel or did you find it uh i can't
remember i don't know i remember i found
out
in my head like a neuralizer for men in
black i want it
the only evidence is that video i don't
want to remember that we found a ton of
hotels in chicago that looked really bad
bleak really really rough hotels but
because i think no one stays there no